let's continue we don't know what sort
of can of worms we're opening here but
we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's take our next caller from the 949
area code that's an area code we've done
well with in the past caller what's your
name and where are you calling from
hello David my name is Isaiah Roe from
Orange County California great what's on
your mind today uh uh right now I'm in
college I'm a junior and I was wondering
uh back when you were in college or in
high school uh what type of jobs were
you thinking about having in the future
like I would imagine before uh what you
are now you had some other ideas or some
other jobs that you thought you might
want to have that would maybe be more uh
you know uh realistic at the time yeah
or maybe jobs were like you're not
called a dirty Jew 20 times a day like
normal jobs I guess you would say yeah
yeah yeah normal jobs well I think when
I was in when I was a high school senior
I wanted to be a firefighter but then by
the time I got to college I wanted to be
a policeman yeah no I'm kidding around
okay that was more when I was like 5 and
6 you know something like that you know
I really didn't know I mean I think that
was part of Isaiah why like I went
straight into graduate school from
undergrad because I just wasn't sure
what I wanted to do and while I was an
undergraduate student at the University
of Massachusetts and Amherst I started
sort of like the first iteration of the
David Pakman show and I liked it at the
time it wasn't a business it wasn't a
job it was sort of a hobby that I was
doing and barely doing at that I might
add and and that's you know I went
directly into grad school and just sort
of figured out you know my colleagues in
grad school they're becoming financial
advisors they're going to work at banks
and stuff like that didn't really appeal
to me and that's why I just sort of
naturally became this idea of hey maybe
I can turn the show into a job of some
some kind but I don't know I mean I
think I definitely was thinking along
the lines of some kind of you know what
I knew I
didn't want was something really rigid
where it's like well we expect you to
just be sitting at your desk from 8:45
in the morning until 5:00 10:00 and
you're allowed a 12 minute break
sometime between noon and 1:30 and and
sort of that type of thing and doing one
type of task so I knew I didn't want
that and I never really did too well
having sort of like a direct supervisor
or boss and so I think it was more
circumstance that led to me taking the
path I did cool I was wondering do you
ever want to be like maybe like a high
school teacher or any man like that
never never never not that there's
anything okay all nighters right I've
had great high school teachers but it
did not occur to me to be a high school
teacher
all right Isaiah always great to hear
from you I recognize you from the from
the the world of YouTube super chats is
that right uh yes I have given a fairly
decent amount and super chats yeah
Isaiah is a super chat all-star I would
say hall-of-famer
all right Isaiah hope to hear from you
again thanks so much for the call thank
you all right